we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
last week i said i don't gloat when an
anti-vaxxed person dies of covet i don't
we got a really strong voicemail from
the eggman who we haven't heard from for
a little while
he has a different perspective on this
take a listen hi dave
you and pat keep talking about the
anti-vaxxers
and like ashley babbitt and all these
people are victims and you feel that you
have empathy you feel bad for them
um i have empathy i'm sorry eggman
you call them victims they're victims of
misinformation
dave i'm gloating and they're deaf just
like they gloated in rbg's
death okay here's a deal right you have
to be
proposed for some reason in some way to
fall for that um
those those fakes i think eggman means
predisposed
facts okay they're victims they're
victims of their own hatred and racist
uh feelings they're not innocent in this
you tell two people that the the
the vaccine doesn't work one believes it
one doesn't
one that doesn't believe it doesn't
believe it for reasons they already have
predetermined in their own mind
racist [ __ ] up hateful reasons so
they're not innocent
you feel so bad but aren't they victims
because they were indoctrinated into
that is my point
for ashley babbitt she's a horrible
freaking person
i say dave i'm just saying we need to
have less empathy for them because they
have no empathy for
us wow so basically it's like an eye for
an eye from the eggman the liberals will
never win
if we feel bad for them and think of
them as victims they think of themselves
as victims
and you're feeding that the ideology has
to be rooted out
i don't suggest we do anything short of
a hundred and ten percent rooting out
the ideology
but gloating about the death seems like
it's over the line for me
and i think most people in the audience
agree we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today
texas texas state senate has passed a
bill
to remove required lessons about civil
rights movements from the curricula
of public schools horrifying a utah
pharmacist
gave a bunch of people cards saying they
had been vaccinated
when they had not been vaccinated and
lastly we are about to see the first
trump rioter
sentenced what are we expecting what are
the charges
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com